federal authorities are investigating
how a so-called unauthorized passenger
boarded a flight from Los Angeles to
Tokyo police interviewed some of the
passengers after that plane returned to
LA last night on the pond Airways flight
175 had been in the air for about four
hours when it turned around and flew
home Don Dahler is here with the
mysterious trip to nowhere and the
celebrity couple that was first to
report it Don good morning good morning
passengers tell CBS News the possibly
unauthorized flier was a young adult
male who seemed to be trying to switch
seats he drew the attention of flight
attendants and their response drew the
attention of one disgruntled passenger
with more than nine million Twitter
followers
hey guys Chrissy Teigen here reporting
live from LAX supermodel Chrissy Teigen
documented all of Nippon Airways flight
175 s eight hour trip from LAX back to
LAX thank you so much for taking me on
this awesome vacation day
she and her husband actor and musician
John Legend were on the flight to Tokyo
before it was forced to turn around the
plane left LAX at around 11:30 a.m. it
was roughly four hours into an 11 and a
half hour flight when the pilot made a
u-turn at 7:30 p.m. the plane was back
in Los Angeles after all this I will
have spent eight hours on a flight to
nowhere Tegan tweeted in a statement to
CBS News aana said the cabin crew became
aware that one of the passengers boarded
the incorrect flight as part of the
airline security procedure the pilot in
command decided to return to the
originating airport whether or not there
was an unauthorized passenger remains
unclear a spokesperson for lax police
told CBS News there were no security
breaches and there was no unauthorized
passenger I've never seen people walk
around was like a clicker and like click
people Naomi commandante said things on
the plane seemed off when the flight
attendants started manually counting
passengers she said she had to turn to
the Internet and to Teagan's tweets for
answers Google what was going on and for
us to read an article about us
the FBI says no arrests have been made
and the investigation continues
passengers tell CBS News that the crew
was apologetic and equally upset by the
turnaround one traveler told us he was
missing the first day of his honeymoon
and that all he was getting back for was
a brief hotel stay or a two hundred
dollar credit so in this case I guess
CBS stands for the Krissi Broadcasting
System if they had an intrepid reporter
on Twitter I just wish they'd get the
miles for the eight-hour or the trip
that they made anywhere they go back
hopefully Jon provided some in-flight
entertainment